[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24 la
asamblea nacional de Venezuela elegida
en el 2015 votó para la eliminación de
la figura del gobierno interino liderado
por Juan guaidó bajo el argumento de ser
una estrategia política fallida guaidó
afirmó que la medida beneficiará al
gobierno de Nicolás maduro
en Estados Unidos tras una demanda del
gobierno por invadir terrenos federales
y dañar el medio ambiente las
autoridades del estado de Arizona se
vieron obligadas a eliminar el muro de
contenedores instalado en la ya
militarizada y concurrida frontera con
México
y el senado de Estados Unidos aprobó una
ayuda de 45.000 millones de dólares para
Ucrania una suma que se integra al gasto
de 1,7 billones de dólares aprobado para
el aumento de la inversión militar que
contempla misiles y equipos de logística
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González vamos a comenzar en nuestra
región en América Latina exactamente en
Venezuela en donde los ex diputados de
la asamblea nacional elegida en el 2015
votaron a favor de eliminar la figura
del gobierno interino que lidera el
opositor Juan guaidó en una primera
sesión los ex diputados votaron 72 votos
a favor de la eliminación y 23 en contra
lo que deja en la cuerda floja la
permanencia de Juan guaidó como rostro
de la oposición política contra el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro un segundo
debate tendrá lugar el 29 de diciembre y
será en esa fecha cuando el legislativo
tome una decisión definitiva
Cuáles herramientas tenemos hoy para
enfrentar a esta dictadura la unidad la
primera reforzado hoy con la plataforma
unitaria y la convocatoria primaria
también el acuerdo de gobernabilidad
parlamental que debe respetar este
departamento nacional para conservar el
poder legítimo que de nuevo y como le
decía Hace unos días se lo digo a
Venezuela se instala el 5 de enero a
pesar de las pretensiones también de la
dictadura de querer acabar con el
parlamento electo en 2018 las
autoridades del estado de Arizona en
Estados Unidos acordaron eliminar el
gigantesco muro de contenedores que está
instalado en la frontera con México los
expertos han señalado que pone en
peligro numerosas especies que están
amenazadas Valentina Torres Sánchez nos
cuenta más
son más de 900 los contenedores que
fueron ubicados en el bosque nacional
Coronado en la frontera sur del estado
de Arizona y ahora tendrán que ser
removidos el gobernador republicano
tras la demanda Federal presentada a
principios de diciembre el muro fue
diseñado para disuadir el paso de
migrantes irregulares calificado de
siniestro por el gobernador pero la
demanda indica que los contenedores
fueron ubicados de forma ilegal en
terrenos federales y ponen en peligro la
vida Silvestre
ese lugar de una increíble diversidad de
vida Silvestre una de las áreas de
conservación más importantes de todo
Estados Unidos
es una parte de la frontera muy difícil
de cruzar para los migrantes y hasta
donde sabemos no hay mucha actividad
migratoria
el plazo para remover los contenedores
se cumple el próximo cuatro de enero dos
días después de que la demócrata Katy
hobbes asuma como gobernadora
la situación se presenta justamente
cuando crece el temor por la llegada de
miles de migrantes a ciudades del Norte
de México mientras esperan que expire el
llamado título 42 que permitía la
expulsión Express por motivos sanitarios
la nueva oleada ha hecho que las
autoridades de México y Estados Unidos
aumenten la presencia militar pero los
migrantes no están dispuestos a
retirarse estamos en Navidad muchos
están compartiendo con su familia uno se
tuvo que venir fuera de su familia
y sus hijos pasando necesidad Pues hay
un 24 de diciembre que tú no sabes dónde
van a dormir en principio quedaba
derogada el 21 de diciembre pero la
Corte Suprema lo aplazó hasta el día 27
la normativa ha permitido expulsar a más
de un millón de migrantes y su
eliminación significa una luz de
esperanza en su búsqueda por una nueva
vida
y seguimos en Estados Unidos porque este
país Tal parece que vivirá la Navidad
más fría desde 1980 así lo indicó el
servicio meteorológico de ese país al
anunciar que la mayoría de los estados
se verán afectados por una tormenta
invernal que ya está provocando el
descenso considerable de las
temperaturas unos 2000 vuelos han sido
cancelados Andrés triviño nos cuenta más
en el siguiente informe
Estados Unidos vivirá una vida más fría
en cuatro décadas casi todos los estados
del país sienten los estragos de la gran
tormenta invernal Elliot la cual deja
más de 90 millones de personas en alerta
máxima principalmente en el medio oeste
y la región de los grandes lagos por lo
que las autoridades han estado a sus
ciudadanos a tomarse en serio la
tormenta
no es un día de nieve normal como cuando
eran niños en serio y mi equipo está
listo para ayudar a las comunidades a
sobrellevar esta tormenta
se espera que Durante los próximos días
Elliot se convierta en una bomba
ciclónica con ráfa viento tan fuertes
que pueden alcanzar el equivalente a un
huracán categoría 3 provocando hasta 30
centímetros de nieve y temperaturas
entre los 10 y los 20 grados bajo cero
este jueves Más de 2.200 vuelos fueron
cancelados y se espera que la situación
empeore tanto en las vías como en los
aeropuertos siendo una de las
festividades en las que los
estadounidenses más se movilizan debido
a que tenemos que movernos más despacio
tenemos que establecer programar o
reducir nuestro horario
ha sido un poco loco llegué temprano
para asegurarme de tomar mi vuelo y a la
puerta de embarque cuando me enteré que
Fue cancelado las aerolíneas
estadounidenses anunciaron que trabajan
para que Los viajeros puedan reunirse en
Navidad y eliminarán las tarifas de
cambio a Los afectados por la tormenta
a menos de 10 días de asumir el cargo el
presidente electo de Brasil Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva dio a conocer parte de lo
que será su gabinete de ministros entre
los nombramientos se destacan algunas
figuras ya conocidas de la escena
política brasileña también es
representantes de los pueblos
afrodescendientes e indígenas hasta
ahora hay seis mujeres seleccionadas más
detalles en el informe de Rafael Pérez
son los primeros nombres del gabinete de
Lula el presidente electo de Brasil
anunció a 16 de sus nuevos ministros que
asumirán junto a él el primero de enero
los ministerios asignados fueron entre
otros Salud Educación ciencia y
tecnología relaciones exteriores defensa
cultura igualdad racial y Derechos
Humanos destacan entre los designados la
asignación del vicepresidente electo
Gerardo alquim en el Ministerio de
industrias y comercio exterior aniel
Franco hermana de la asesinada activista
Mariel y Franco y Silvio Almeida un
activista contra el racismo estarán al
frente de los departamentos de igualdad
racial y Derechos Humanos
respectivamente dos de sus hombres de
confianza figuran en la lista rui Costa
estará al frente del Ministerio de la
presidencia mientras que Fernando jadad
ex alcalde de Sao Paulo estará a cargo
de Hacienda El canciller será Mauro
vieira quien ya realizó estas funciones
bajo las órdenes de Dilma Rousseff Lula
anunció que aumentará 37 los ministerios
el actual gobierno con 23 no soy yo
quien necesita a los ministros que
anunciamos es el pueblo brasileño quien
los necesita los pobres las mujeres la
población negra nuestro compromiso es
con el pueblo y estoy seguro de que
sabremos cumplirlo aún no se conoce
quién dirigirá el Ministerio de medio
ambiente uno de los nombramientos más
esperados incluso a nivel internacional
entre el paquete militar de ayuda que
Estados Unidos enviará a Ucrania se
contempla una batería de misiles armas y
elementos de logística desde el kremlin
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
desestimó el potencial de este sistema
de defensa y también criticó la ayuda
proporcionada a Ucrania
el viaje de boladimir selensky a
Washington se saldó con un millonario
paquete de ayuda militar para Ucrania y
no hay duda de Cuál es la pieza central
[Aplausos]
de casi dos mil millones de dólares y el
elemento más fuerte de este paquete es
el sistema patreon reforzará
significativamente nuestra defensa aérea
es un paso importante en la creación de
un escudo aéreo eficaz para Ucrania
el sistema de misiles tierra aire ha
sido fabricado desde 1976 por el grupo
armamentístico estadounidense raiden
saltó a la fama durante la Guerra del
Golfo de 1991 y ha sido un equipo básico
para el ejército estadounidense y muchos
de sus aliados Ucrania recibirá una
batería contiene 4 misiles pack 2 como
un alcance de 160 kilómetros o 16
misiles pack 3 con un alcance de 40
kilómetros kiev que la adquisición del
sistema cambie las reglas del juego en
la guerra con Rusia permitiéndole
rastrear y derribar mejor los misiles
balísticos pero una sola batería tendrá
un efecto limitado
los sistemas que ya tienen los nazam los
Santi los Iris no pueden funcionar
realmente bien para eso están los
Patriots y francamente si el objetivo es
el VIP ni Pro harkif un sistema
desplegado alrededor de kiev no va a
alcanzar esos objetivos no van a acertar
esos misiles necesitarán muchos más
Patriots
hasta que Ucrania no aumente su
capacidad con los patreon es poco
probable que los nuevos misiles tengan
un efecto decisivo en la guerra pero sí
una mayor capacidad para repeler los
ataques cierto alivio para la población
de kiev que sufre frecuentes bombardeos
esto en las noticias siga con nosotros
buenas noches
[Música]